OK. Um, good afternoon,
everyone, and welcome to the session on agentic
AI meets responsible AI strategy
and best practices.
So continuing the theme of reinvent where
it seems that all things agentic are
front and center.
Um, today, um, along with
my colleague Peter Hainan, who's sitting over here
and will take over shortly,
um,
uh, I'll outline things in a second. We,
we don't just tell you some,
you know, some basics about agentic AI.
And I'm gonna talk a little bit about the scientific
challenges behind it
and, and possibly anticipated
solutions to those and then Peter will talk
more about
industrial evolution and, and practicalities.
Um So just the agenda,
I'm gonna start and just kind of level set us
all and talk about what
what agents are and what agentic AI means,
um, then spend most of my time talking about scientific
frontiers or more, more accurately
challenges,
um, and then Peter will take over and,
and talk about more practical topics.
Um,
so just to
kind of, um, give some kind of spectrum
along which we can arrange agentic AI,
I, I think the word agentic
and agentic AI is probably, um,
terminology that's a little bit too crude
for the vast spectrum of things that are covered.
I'm sure many of you are familiar with are familiar with
and are perhaps regular users of large
language models.
And so we're all used to the phenomenon of interacting
with a large language model in a dialogue and a
turn taking basis.
I think the logical extreme of agentic AI
is an LLM based system
that has access to unfettered
access to external resources
information and can take consequential,
possibly irreversible actions in
the real world.
So think things like, you know, engaging in financial
transactions on your behalf, signing
contracts on your behalf,
or even more consequentially taking military
actions or medical decision making actions
autonomously.
I don't know of any agentic system
right now that that touches that
logical extreme or comes even close
to it, which is why I think we need language for the
stuff that's in between.
But in this, in this chart what
we're doing is sort of arranging systems
along the particular dimension of what level
of autonomy the agent has.
So at one end we have sort of
just turn taking interactions with an LLM possibly
in service
of completing a task or getting information,
um. And in the middle I think um
is where most of the action will be in the near
term and that is around what I'm gonna shortly
call kind of planning agents. These
are agents that
can do that you don't need to hold their hand
on a turn by turn dialogue make um
dialogue making basis.
You can give them a high level goal and
ask them to plan and execute the steps
to it and expect that it, you know, will
make forward progress, possibly get stuck and
revise its plan and continue,
um. And so, um,
what are some examples of agents that I kind of have
in mind? Well, I think one example
that that people often think in mind is
sort of a,
um agentic executive assistant.
So what do I mean by an agentic executive assistant?
This would be somebody that has access to and
knows everything about your schedule, your
calendar, your commitments,
your travel preferences, the con, you know,
whether you like to sit in aisle or window seats,
the conditions under which you might be willing to
pay for an upgrade to first class on a long
international flight,
and the like,
and actually has the ability to again
engage in transactions for you, to go out
and find tickets that you, the, the
tickets you might have bought yourself and purchased them
for you. Um, by advanced
planning agents, I mean agents that can,
as I said,
just take a high level specification
and
plan the steps to execute that task.
And so let me
digress for a second and tell you about a
little experience I had over the summer.
Um, so, um, as you might have noticed on
the title slide, I am what's known as an Amazon
scholar, which means that I divide my
time between Amazon.
And the computer science faculty at the
University of Pennsylvania. So I'm a
career-long machine learning researcher. I started
working in the field in the late 1980s. So
suffice to say I've seen an alarming amount of
change in the last four decades or so.
And um
this summer a faculty colleague and
I and a visiting graduate student actually
wrote from scratch
a roughly 50 page mathematical
paper from scratch
with the help of kind of a coding based
LLM tool and so I'm gonna tell you a little
bit more about that experience.
So many of you I'm sure are quite familiar with
and perhaps are regular users again of
coding agents where you can basically
say, well, I wanna write some Python code
that does the following and you interact with it.
Um, in, in natural language, and
it actually writes the code for you and
can run experiments for you and the like.
So I, I think really just in the last
year these systems have also become
quite proficient at proving theorems,
OK? So we wrote this paper
describing kind of what the high level
results we thought were like what the theorem statements
would look like, and we didn't know all the details
because you don't know all the details and you act till you actually
prove the theorem. So we didn't know things like what the exact
convergence rate of our proposed algorithm
would be, but we wanted to
basically prove that it would converge to something
good and then, you know, kind of quantify the rate.
And so we did this in sort of a turn taking
way. So we would say like, well, here's the high
level statement of the theorem, here are what we think the
steps of the proof are,
we think you'll need this tool from probability
theory in this step and you know, why don't you try and
then we would interact with it and correct it and go
back and forth.
And then somewhere midway
through this project, my colleague noticed that there was
a little button at the bottom of the interface that
said turbo mode,
and it turns out that in turbo mode you could just say,
here's the theorem I want you to prove. I'm going
away for a few hours, why don't you try to prove it?
And as you may, if you've used these systems,
you know, they talk to themselves and so suddenly
scrolling starts happening in grayed out
text and you see the model talking to
itself and saying, oh, that didn't work. I
see what I did wrong. I should go back and fix this.
And sometimes when we did this, we would
come back and it would still just, it would be churning
away, you know, nonsensically we would be stuck
in some very, very bad state.
Other times we would come back and we'll see
that, you know, actually 45 minutes after
we left, it had done exactly what we asked
it to. And I think we'll see
a lot of this kind of agent
in the near future where you just
specify the high level goal
um maybe with as much detail as
you're able to specify and then you
just let the model run and plan
its own steps and backtrack
and and as needed and
and go forward.
So let me now turn to
what I consider to be some of the
interesting scientific challenges of agentic
AI. And as a scientist, by
the way, I'm, I'm, I'm usually most comfortable
talking about known science, about, you know,
what's out there
on a particular topic.
Um, in this case, I can't do that
because despite the buzz
around agentic AI, not just at reinvent,
but in the scientific community.
There's not a lot of literature
specifically on the topic of agentic
AI, OK?
And um that's obviously going to
change very soon.
But let me start, start off by talking
about the native language of AI embeddings,
uh, of AI agents or embeddings.
So when we interact with a large
language model in in a natural
language like English,
um, the LLMs don't actually
directly work on, on that,
um, English language content.
They actually map anytime you
give an LLM input, whether it's in the form
of an English prompt or an image
or you point it at a
code base or you point it at all
of the documents so far in the legal
case, the first thing it does is
transform that data into
a still high dimensional but much lower
dimensional space, and the primary
purpose of that transformation
is to preserve similarities
between content.
So for instance, in an image embedding
model, 222
photos of different families would be
placed nearer to each other in embedding
space than either one of those family photos
would be to say a landscape.
Two romance novels would be put
closer to each other in a language embedding
space than they either would be to
a car user manual, for instance.
Um, and so on, and, and so
the high level idea of embeddings is to
re-represent data
in a way that captures similarity between
data rather than the raw data itself. And, and
by the way,
if you've ever had the sort of disturbing experience
of an LLM
seeming to completely lose its place
in the dialogue that it's having with you
or suddenly return to some
topic that you were discussing hours or
days ago
completely out of the blue.
It's because actually there's no memorization
of the dialogue so far by the LLM
there is just the embedding of the dialogue
so far, and this leads to these kind of
cognitive ticks that you sometimes see
less as time goes on, but they're, they're
still there.
Um,
and so we should anticipate that
agentic AI, since it's based on
LLMs, will also basically reason
in embedding space rather than in
the, the sort of superficial
input space that we give it, whether it be language
or images or code or what have you.
Um, and so I think there's some interesting implications
to this. I, I don't think we,
you know, one of the things that's hard about AI
and LLMs and deep learning in general
is that these re-representations of the data
are very powerful,
but we still have very poor understanding of,
of the, of what, what's really. Going
on and what they mean. So in particular,
in the same way if we,
you know, opened up your cortex
and pointed a particular neuron in your cortex
for the most part except in very simple cases
like low level visual processing,
we don't actually know what the particular
purpose of that neuron is
in the, in the same way we really don't know
what the meaning of embedding space is in the
in the cartoon here on the right where
um um the.
The idea in this cartoon is that you know
several different users have eaten at different
restaurants and maybe given them different different
ratings and preferences
and so, um,
you know, you have that raw data and then you wanna map
that to embedding space
and in this particular cartoon one thing that's
inaccurate about it
just for the purposes of simplification is that
the axes are labeled by particular
properties we know like what what is the quality
of the food, what is the ambiance of the restaurant, etc.
But embedding space, you know, the label the
axes would basically be entirely unlabeled,
they would have no direct semantics that we
could interpret.
And so one of the, I think,
um, near term implications of this
is that when you think about
agents going out on our behalf and consuming
or finding content and interacting
with other agents,
you know, even though they're quite proficient at conversing
with us in English,
they won't converse with each other in
English, and they won't, and they don't
need English in order to understand
content. And so for instance, I, I
predict that at some point in the not too distant
future.
Every website on the Internet
will, you know, have a little place where
that basically says if you're an agent,
here is the pre-computed embedding of all
of the content on this website
because it makes no sense for every single agent
that goes to that website to have to recomput
the embedding itself,
you know, you may as well just pre-comput it and put it
there. And you know this
can't happen today because these embedding models
are, you know,
proprietary and so they're not
standardized, but I predict that there will be
some amount of standardization that will make this possible
because it's just one of these things that makes practical
sense. Um
OK. Um, and I, I think another,
another area where embeddings
are.
Important and that we don't
understand quite well yet is when it comes
to things like privacy and security.
So if you think about embeddings,
you know, taking the original data
and mapping it to some abstract space
whose primary goal is to preserve
distances,
you know, the data is gonna get warped
through that transformation, and we don't understand
sort of the shape or properties of that warping.
And so in particular, you know, we have all
these divisions in our mind about different types
of data. So for instance, when I think about my
data, I think of my, you know, financial
history as being
generally quite separate from my medical
history. These are different types of data for different types
of functions.
There's no guarantee when my data
gets mapped into embedding spaces that
that sort of clear separation that I have in
my mind will still exist
and so this has privacy implications. So
in particular
when your, you know, agentic executive
system assistant is shopping
around for
plane tickets for you and deciding whether you,
you, you would want to pay for an upgrade to
first class.
You know, if a
human executive assistant was doing that,
they wouldn't take into account, you know, how your
stock portfolio had been performing recently,
even though in principle that is financial
information that might have bearing on your willingness to pay
for a first class ticket.
There's kind of, I, I think without safeguards
put in place, there's no particular guarantee
that your agentic executive assistant
would realize that that same boundary
should be obeyed because of this blurring of
of different data types and the blurring
of boundaries in data space and
obviously this has privacy and security
implications as well
and there's a very, very small
literature. The last time I checked a couple of papers
on the very good question
of if I have some data that's privacy
sensitive.
And I compute an embedding of it into some
lower dimensional space,
how much can you reverse engineer
about the original raw data just from the embedding?
And you know, the reason that there's a paper on this
is that the answer is, you know,
you, you can do some reverse engineering
and so we'll need to start
rethinking, I think, basic tenets
and models around things like privacy,
security, encryption, and the like
in an agentic AI world.
OK. So I've used a couple of
examples when your agent was going out and
performing transactions for you,
and we might also anticipate a future
where your agent is going out and negotiating
things for you, essentially engaged, not
just kind of going out and engaging in transactions.
And you might expect that in the same way for
for many years now
we've had websites that basically try to crawl
and find the best prices for you on flights
that there will be agents that try to do that for
you and so you can imagine your agentic
AI assistant in service
of get making travel arrangements for you
kind of bartering or negotiating
with an a uh another agent.
So, you know, what might that look
like? Well,
um,
there's a, there's an also a small
but pretty rapidly growing literature,
not just in the AI
machine learning community, but in the social sciences
as well.
In which there there are studies that
that try to replicate
or study the analog
of human behavior in agents
and LLMs. OK, and so let me tell
you about the first example of this
that I, I know from about 4
years ago from a colleague and friend of mine.
So in behavioral game theory
there's something known as the ultimatum game.
What is the ultimatum game? An ultimatum game is,
well, first of all, it's a very simple kind of math
problem that I'll describe to you in a second,
but it's also more interestingly
a behavioral experiment that economists
have been running for many, many decades now
in many, many cultures, varying
certain conditions of the setup and so on. But
the basic setup is the following.
You bring two players into a lab, let's call
them Alice and Bob.
And you say, OK, Alice, you get to move first
and you can propose any split
of $10 that you want with Bob,
OK? Then Bob
responds and Bob can either accept
the split that Alice has proposed, in
which case you actually pay the two
participants their respective pieces.
Or Bob can reject
and then both players get nothing,
OK? So,
you know, what does game theory or microeconomics
predict about this? It's very, very simple, you
know, you know, Bob,
Alice and Bob being perfectly
rational beings, right?
Alice, you know, should reason as follows.
Since Bob is perfectly rational,
I should offer the smallest non-zero
amounts to Bob, say a penny, OK?
And so Alice would propose 9.99
and a penny.
Bob, being rational,
you know, would rather have a penny than not have a
penny, and so Bob accepts. OK.
This isn't that interesting.
What is interesting is that when you run this
game in the lab, nothing even remotely
close to this happens, but what does
happen is extremely consistent
across many conditions and cultures.
What happens is
almost all of the time, let's say close to 90%
of the time, Alice will offer.
To Bob something between $5.03
dollars,
very rarely more than $5
and so you know there's, there's sort of a priming for
both players already that Alice being in a
position of power by moving first
might, might deserve more of the, the, the pie
than than half.
Conditioned on Alice's proposal
to Bob being within that 3 to $5
range,
Bob almost always accepts the
acceptance rate is extremely high,
and in the 10 10% or
so cases where Alice
gets more aggressive and offers
Bob something less than $3
the rejection rate of Bob skyrockets
to close to 100%.
So you can go look this
up. It's been performed. This experiment
has been run hundreds, possibly thousands of
times.
And one of the things that's interesting about it,
is that first of all, it deviates from the
mathematical prediction by a lot.
The other thing is that it's very, very
consistent
across different subjects and cultures and
so it's as if we all neurologically
have a hardwired sense,
uh, a shared hardwired sense of what's
fair in this game,
even though probably most of you have never heard
of the ultimatum game before right now.
So my colleague basically went out and
replicated this experiment
using LLMs instead of Alice
and Bob.
So he would say to one LLM and he would give them
personas also, right? He would say, you know,
to, to sort of match the variability
of human subjects that you would get in a laboratory
experiment.
So he would give a prompt to one LM and
say, you know.
Uh, you know,
your name is Melissa. You're a 37
year old medical technician living in Lexington,
Kentucky. You get to propose any
split, and then he would, you know, give a, a prompt
to the other LLM,
and you know, guess what happens?
The LLMs actually statistically
almost perfectly match the behavior of
human subjects that I mentioned.
And so now this is becoming quite an area
within not just AI and machine learning but
the social sciences more generally and
so people are starting to study what happens when
agents negotiate with each other when they
bargain with each other and
interesting phenomena are, are starting
to arise. In general,
the tracking of human behavior is quite good
and, and also sort of tracking of
human foibles as well. So for
instance, it's
there was a recent paper about a year ago that
showed. That LLMs
engaged in kind of a price negotiation
game essentially arrived at outcomes
that would be considered collusion and
price fixing from a regulatory standpoint
and, and you know this is both amusing
but I think it's also worth thinking about.
That when we think about agentic
AI,
we don't just need to think about what happens with
individual agents in, you know, in
the same way that we think in game theory or finance
about collective behavior or emergent phenomena.
We need to think about that with agentic
AI as well.
And so, you know, you might wonder.
You know, if we soon arrive at a world
where a lot of activity, including financial
and strategic activity, is
mediated by agents,
you know, whether we might,
how will we think about things like hurting behavior
in stock markets or things like
system, the systemic risk that led
to
the 2008 financial crash, you
know, so these are examples of kind of cases
where. The behavior of any
individual agent might seem perfectly
natural or rational, but you
arrive at some collective outcome that is,
is quite undesirable.
So the, the, the last topic I
wanna mention is maybe the one that's
fuzziest and that on which I really
don't know any
kind of current
kind of science around,
which is the challenge of what I would call subjective
common sense.
And so let me first talk about common sense
rather than subjective common sense.
So
you know, I, I will use the fact
that I've been around forever in this field to,
to tell you that
for the longest time, the, the,
the
AI and machine learning were kind of confounded
by the problem of imbuing models with
common everyday common sense.
And so by common sense I mean
facts that we would all agree on even
if we'd never thought about them before. So
for instance, you know, in the series of pictures.
You know, if I, if I show you a
glass of water sitting on a surface on a
table, let's say,
and then I shift it in one direction,
say I shift it to the right,
you know, we would all still agree
that it's still a glass of water on
that surface, right? The fact that, you know, that
I've moved it somewhere on the table doesn't
change the fact that it's a glass of water
sitting on the table.
And we would also all know that, you know, if I tip
it on its side,
it's still a glass on a table, but it's no
longer a glass of water anymore, OK.
And so for the longest time in AI,
you know, I think dating back to the
beginning of the field,
the, the people struggled with the
question of how to imbue
models and AI systems,
you know, not just with the ability to perform
extremely targeted tasks very well like
face recognition, but to just have this sort
of ability to do common sense everyday
reasoning that any human being could do.
And somehow, you know, in the last
15 years or so that problem
has largely been solved. I mean, I,
I have a colleague at at Duke who
spends, as far as I can tell,
spends all of his time posting on social
media
examples of LLM's
kind of failing basic common sense things,
but for the most part this has gotten much better.
And I think this is just due to the fact that you
know if a if a model sees
a fact or you know images of
glasses on tables sitting upright
and tipped on their side enough, it'll learn
this. By subjective common
sense, I mean kind of
heuristics that you have around your own
behavior that are perfectly sensible,
that you have good reasons for, but
are personal to you, are not shared
like our knowledge about glasses of water
on tables.
And so as an example, I will just
use my own behavior around,
you know, whether I leave doors.
Open or closed or locked or unlocked,
OK, and I invite you to think about your own
behaviors in this regard,
you know, it's actually quite complicated,
right? So in my office,
um, you know, when I leave for the day,
I, I lock my office behind me when
I'm there during the day, you know,
sometimes I leave the door open and I'm in my
office. Sometimes I'm in my office and
I close the door, but I don't lock it. Because I'm
taking a meeting or I wanna be able to focus.
And sometimes when I'm just gonna be nearby
on the floor or at a whiteboard out in the hall,
I will leave my door open and
unlocked
to kind of signal that I'm around
but just not in there at the moment, OK?
And, and you, you, you probably all
have similar heuristics and they
will probably all differ slightly
than, than mine.
And so I, I think that kind of
imbuing agentic AI with
this sort of personalized subjective
common sense
is gonna be a real challenge because it can't
be unlike things like
facts about glasses of water on tables,
it can't be learned from data. There's not
mass, there's, there's not a massive
trove of data out there
on my particular habits regarding,
you know, um,
uh, doors and locking, OK.
And whether lest this example
sort of seems too far removed or abstract,
I invite you to sort of just swap
doors and locking with accounts
and passwords, right?
So perhaps many of you choose
to share,
you know, the passwords to your Spotify
or Netflix accounts with other family
members or people that you're close to,
but you wouldn't do the same thing with your bank
account probably, OK?
And so how agentic AI
is gonna somehow, I, I think we're kind of
returning to the 70s, right? where nobody
had any idea how we were ever going
to get general common
sense into models and then that turned
machine learning on just sufficiently
massive troves of data turned out to be
a good solution to that.
I don't see that solution working
anytime soon for, you know, your
agentic AI.
OK, and so I think I'm gonna turn
it over to Peter now to come talk about
more practical topics and, and sort of the evolution
of agentic AI in, in particular the
ways in which it's different
than um just LLM based
degenerative AI.
Uh-huh. Um,
so I'm. I'm not on.
Do I need to now you are all right,
but I am too. OK,
well, we can, we can talk together then.
All right, so I'm Peter Helen and I'm the director
of responsible AI for AWS
and I lead a team of scientists and
engineers and
various folks who are interested in
tackling the open science problems
and then translating solutions into
best practices,
uh, for our internal teams
and for customers,
um. So let's
talk a little bit about, uh,
so the, the science challenges I, I hope
are becoming clearer, right? Let's talk about
some of the other challenges
that we face.
Um,
All right, so, so where are we
going in the nearer term with agents?
Let's take a look, um, there's lots of,
uh, effective agents
today or things that are that are
called agents that are effective, right? Here's
a few from, from Amazon, Quiro,
um.
What do we have here? Uh, I can see down here,
OK, uh, the SageMaker model customization
agent, SageMaker data agent, there's
one we just wrote a blog about which is a compliance
screening agent so across our businesses
we have to be very careful about, you know,
the transactions.
So now we have an internal agent that takes care
of that.
But what, what is sort of the,
the primary characteristic of these
agents, right?
Is that they have very close human
interaction.
OK, and you have single vendor
accountability.
So the world that we were just talking
about where we have, you know, lots of critters
running around all doing useful work for
us is
a bit different than this world here. Now this world here
is yielding some value, quite a bit of value,
um,
but we have a ways to go, all right?
So
how might things evolve,
uh, in the over the next year or
two? The first thing is
obviously sort of more task types,
right? So consider an example
where you want to,
you know, use your miles to
get business class tickets,
you know, to Paris, say if you're living in
the US for December, right?
You can do it,
but the airlines release. Those tickets
sort of slowly over time according to
their own schedules. This is a
task where you have to sort of continuously
go back and forth.
Um, it's a bit of drudgery
and something you can forget to do and then you
go oh darn because you missed it, what have you.
So this is the kind of thing where
you know the agent should be released
to do
something over a period of
time. It's not a, it's not a fast
response. Another one might be, hey,
look, there's interesting social media
conversations, but you want the comments to accumulate
in some way before you spend your time.
You don't want to go back to it repeatedly.
So this is, this is a trend I
would call sort of fast to slow.
You could call it short term to long term if
you want to,
but it's, uh, it's, it's a different
type of, of task.
Here's a second trend, and by the way, the
three trends I'm gonna talk about right here are correlated,
they're not independent,
um. But the second type
is
that not every task
needs to be explicitly specified
by the user,
so you could trigger a log analysis
from a ticket,
right? We have an agent, DevOps agent,
that's, uh, doing things like that,
or you know, you have an agent
that listening to traffic reports and
in this sort of ideal personal assistant,
uh, view, you know, it, it
updates your restaurant reservation because it knows you're
not gonna get there on time.
Um, so these are inferred tasks,
right? And there's sort of an implicit,
uh, assumption here that they're
accessing information and
tracking it so that you don't have to,
um, and so this I would think of as sort
of reactive to proactive,
OK,
um, a third one,
is more connectivity to third party
workflows.
All right, so here we have a nice little
remote, uh, restaurant
off on a lovely beach.
Um, they do have a telephone.
Uh, a landline old school, right,
and then you have your, your state
of the art travel agent that's helping
you out and you ring them up
and then you know someone else has their
state of the art travel agent and then a third
person has and then a whole bunch of
other people have and you've kind of DDoS
the poor
restaurant, right? They just can't cope with
this.
Um, and so
you know this connectivity to third party
workflows is an implicit
part of all the
sort of the magic and the excitement of agents
right when we talk about all the, all
the drudgery that we could eliminate, but
we need to understand how it impacts,
you know, those other systems that we're
talking to.
So here you know. What happens to the restaurant
if Travel Agent one cancels,
you know, it really impacts their
business. They don't have that many tables,
and so you begin to wonder if that
offline restaurant really has
to go get its own matrad agent
to or go out of business or how
it handles this, but it has a business
decision that it needs to confront, right?
And this applies to online workflows
going back to airlines for a minute. You know some
airlines have a policy where you buy the ticket
and then you can change your mind within 24 hours.
Well, that policy is crafted
to deliver, you know, the, the flyer
benefit. It's a, it's a nice policy,
but it's very carefully, you know, driven
by data and what's the likelihood of refusing,
and now they're holding a seat, you know, who do they
risk not selling it, etc. etc.
All of a sudden you put agents in it, the math
changes.
It assuredly changes and
so you know how do these policies, so
we talk about agents, but then we have to also
talk about all the things whether or not
they are agents that the agents are interacting
with and how that change happens, right?
Um, and so,
you know,
from today, you know, we're, we're really
sort of nailing it in a lot of domains
on, on well understood workflows
to the future where we have these sophisticated
goals.
Um,
we see sort of this general trend,
right, and on the X axis. Axis
you have kind of the complexity of the
task from simple to
complex or the complexity
of the user request on
the vertical axis you
have kind of the robustness,
the resiliency, the strength
of the infrastructure.
That you support the agents with
so if you think about that,
you know, the, the, the fastest slow,
well that thing had to be up and running continuously
for a long period of time.
OK,
it's not quite the same as just, you
know, interacting with an LLM if it goes
down the next day that maybe that's fine or what have
you, but like this really takes infrastructure
to support,
um. So anyway,
that's kind of the general trend that
we see happening
now.
How do we realize the benefits while minimizing
the risks,
uh, as this rolls out?
OK,
so a couple of things.
The first observation I wanna
make
is that
when Jen and I hit
the world by storm a few years ago,
um.
It really broadened
the number of folks who are engaging
with AI,
um, and.
You know,
turned it from a sort of a very small
community to a very large community
with, uh, sort of a,
shall I say a lack of understanding
of the difference between
statistical inference, right, and
rule-based logic
and so there's a major mind.
Shift which the industry as a whole
is still in the process of making
right where people realize
that AI is not
just smart software,
it is actually a different kind of beast,
all right, and to highlight some of the, the
changes here,
OK, obviously traditional
software rule-based logic, if
you have a statistical model based on statistical
inference, we'll get to a deeper
implication of that in a second.
You know your specking changes, right?
With the traditional model you can write it down
in English.
You know, with AI you're using
data sets to so to Michael's earlier
point, you know, about where are the data
sets that encode,
you know, all the full range of
your personal preferences and even
do you want to have such data sets,
you know, lying around? I mean that's also a
question, right? But, but the data sets
are key here.
A third point, right, is that with
traditional software
you expect it to work out of the box.
The developer
is responsible for the quality
of that product,
but with the statistical model it's a diff
it's different. The developer anticipates
the kinds of input distributions
that they'll get, but they can't know for sure
their privacy constraints. Like we don't look
at the prompts that come into,
uh, you know. Our bedrock models,
right? And so what you
what you see as a result of this is
that deployers and
in some cases end users
have to also test because they're
the ones that understand
their particular data,
right? So a third point,
sorry, a 4th point
is, OK,
again
you release a piece of software, version N
+ 1, you expect it to work better than
version N on each and every input.
OK,
but for statistical software,
you're, uh, a statistical model,
you're going to expect it
to work on average
better than, and that's a
big difference.
And it might not be on average, it could be your metric
of choice,
but you know you can have, you can
release an improved model, and some
users of it may see
you worse performance.
Um,
and then a final point I want to make about this
kind of mind shift
is that,
you know, with rule-based software,
traditional software, there is a single
explanation for how
you got a particular output from a particular
input. The code can be implemented
in different ways, yes,
but the chain of logic is the same,
whereas on this, in the statistical side,
it's different. In fact, you release
a model,
OK. And that model
does have a logic inside
it, but there's also tens
of thousands or millions of
models that had the exact same
performance that you did not release
that had other chains of logic
inside them, maybe a little bit different, maybe
very different.
Um, so the question of explainability
becomes more complicated.
So, a couple of, of
implications of this.
First of all, on the, on
the sort of,
uh, on the for the AI side,
um. There
are two stacks that you
have to worry about,
uh, and so if we think about an AI
system
and it's you're sort of improving
it version by version on the
horizontal axis and then you're looking at
its performance
along a particular for a particular metric
on the vertical axis,
right, and you, you test it on some data
set, maybe you get this kind of performance,
but you test it on a different data set.
You get a different performance trajectory,
right? You test it on a 3rd data set and
maybe it's altogether, you know, it's
going down.
Right, so performance is a function
of the system and the, the evaluation
data set. It is not a function
of the system by itself,
and I know if some of you have heard us talk
before about this, right,
we're pounding, we're pounding, you know, this point
again and again, but we still need to
get this clear because the result of this,
right, is that you have, if
you're, if you're a developer
of an AI solution, a gen.
Take, you know, uh, generative
traditional, right, you've got your system
stack and then you've got your evaluation stack
and your evaluation stack as the developer
represents what you anticipate
downstream folks to use,
but then you have downstream folks
who are going to
have to have their own stack with
their data to check what's going
on, right.
And as a whole, we are, we are
moving in this direction as an industry,
but this is not a well established
design pattern at this point in time.
All right.
So, what's another implication?
And here we get into what is our sort
of traditional responsible AI slide,
right? The fact is you, you know, statistical
models,
you know, have a variety of technical
properties.
It's not just overall performance.
It includes issues around AI privacy,
AI security, safety, fairness,
veracity, etc. etc. There's a bunch
of these things.
And the models released have
these properties,
whether or not you as a
developer made a decision about the properties.
OK, and that's a very important point.
So if we go back here
to the stack downstream, they can measure
for properties that you may not have made
an explicit design decision about.
All right.
And so when we think of responsible AI,
what we're really thinking about is
getting folks to make explicit
decisions about balancing the, you know, the,
the, the, the desired benefits and
the potential risks,
uh, of a service, right.
Um, that's the goal. You want to make
these decisions explicitly,
not implicitly.
OK.
And I think the last point, uh, is
probably very self-evident, but,
you know, from a product management point of view,
um.
You know life got just got a little more complicated.
You had all the stuff that you had to worry about
before with traditional software and now
you have these other properties.
OK, now it doesn't necessarily mean you have to optimize
every one of these properties. It's perfectly fine
to make a decision that, you know, this
one we'll deal with later or what have you,
um,
uh, as long as you disclose that,
right? Um, but it is
still
additional, these are still additional considerations.
OK, so that was mind
shift one and we haven't yet
completed that mind shift as an industry.
Now come agents because why wait?
Life is exciting, OK?
Um, what is the second
mind shift that's provoked by agents?
Well, there is one,
and let's go back to Alice and
Bob, our canonical,
you know, science friends as we
work through some of these issues, right?
There are things that Agent Alice
uh would like to know about Agent Bob
before Alice interacts with Bob,
OK?
Who are you,
right? Who owns you?
How can you help me,
right? And the reason for this is because
Alice is there to do actual work
and there are decisions that she
needs to make, right? How much
information do I share with you?
Right, that, that does matter. How do I
negotiate
a fair resource exchange with you?
OK, so for example, if you're
gonna have a zero trust posture,
right, are, are you gonna just
like, is it like walking up to a
counter at 7-Eleven and just buying
it and walking off? Maybe not,
uh, maybe not at all, um.
How do you enforce the terms of the exchange?
How much
time or
cost or information
does the agent Alice
want to invest in
this particular transaction, right?
What happens if it gets
detailed and like, like they're sort of going
back and forth on a lot of things
and the agent budget is sitting
there ticking down, right? Like the transaction
will cost money.
At the end of the day, right,
so trust becomes rather
critical here
now,
you know, this isn't the only situation in which
issues of trust come up,
and there's, you know, a variety of
mechanisms to address these. We have
norms. An example of a norm, for example,
like with the Internet is a robots.text
file. OK, there's not a law around robots.text.
It's a norm and it has
some issues. But it, it has, has worked
relatively well.
There's also standards, you know,
um, MCP is an emerging standard,
uh,
TCP IP in the early days
of the Internet, I think some people
maybe regret how long
TCPIP persisted,
right, because it has the, the doubling thing,
um, and then there can be existing AI regulations,
um, but.
This, the, the mindset
shift
that I'm talking about here is
that
you can't, these are not
necessarily.
Core technical problems,
right? These are problems
about privacy, about
the exchange of information, about what do
I do.
There can be a variety, there can be research
that supports the optimization of
these decision making processes,
but you know people themselves make these
kinds of decisions all the time.
They may not be perfectly optimal, um,
but they are functional,
right? We have a civilization.
So this is the
kind of thing that we have to work on, but
we're not going to succeed on it
if we, you know, tackle everything
with a zero trust model and hunker
down. You'll never get that vision of interactions
that are productive, right?
So what does this mean in practice?
So as we think about, you know, sort of
a very simple agent ecosystem
here, we've got 4 agents and 2
humans,
right? The first thing that you're going to need is
the agent infrastructure that we talked
about from the earlier diagram, right?
You need real support.
For a variety of either
short running or long running
interactions,
um, this is the kind of thing that that agent
cop is is shooting towards, but
you also need infrastructure
to help people steward
this emerging ecosystem,
and I use the word stewardship
instead of governance because
you know
this is, this is not this is not
a pure.
Uh, regulatory,
uh, you know, challenge, um,
it's not a challenge that has
one person who's,
uh, accountable for this,
you know, it's sort of a community working
together to, to have it happen.
So let me give you one specific example
of what I mean. So today.
You know, if you look, go to an Amazon
Nova model, right,
the, the images are watermarked,
and so there's a service out there and you
can submit the image and
it'll decide whether or not that
that image actually has the Nova
watermark, OK.
Now what happens
um and so we have that sort of piece
of infrastructure,
you know, colored in in blue up
there on the screen, right?
So what happens if every agent
starts checking, you know,
for the provenance of any image
that it accepts either from a human
or another thing because it needs to know, right? Say
for, for, for IP reasons
where that image came from.
Um, all right, well,
right now that infrastructure for the Watermark
checker is designed for
pretty much, you know, it has an API and it's
humans, but it's not designed for
billions
of agents to all of a sudden
start talking to it. It's going to go down.
So how. Is that gonna be supported,
developed,
funded, right? You can imagine other
kinds of checking infrastructure where
it's, it's engaged in
each transaction that involves
novel content or maybe even, you know, non-novel
content and there can be other pieces of infrastructure
as well,
um, that that may turn out to be relevant,
but all this has yet to be invented,
OK.
So, um.
Anyway, so what do we do today? Let's
get really down to brass tacks,
um, because we're still working through
Mindshift one and because agents
at their core are based on foundation
models,
OK,
um.
You know, a lot of the work
of building an individual agent
is similar to the work of building
any other AI solution.
All right, so we have at
this reinvent
released a
um what I would call sort of a framework
for best practices
to help
non-ML experts
uh develop AI
applications and it's available
online via our well architected
tool
so anyone can go to that uh
QR code
URL and see it,
but the notion is that.
We want to provide
people with a set of
questions.
To help them think about
the decisions that they need to
make and then for each question
we offer some best practices,
right? That will, that will sort of
uh help answer those
questions. So
let's,
let's go through a couple of
examples on the agent side.
So one of these, and, and I should say that
the, the design of the framework
is such that
you start with a narrowly defined use
case,
right? Because if you want to actually
um evaluate,
uh, and you know,
make a, a data-driven
decision about how well a
particular system.
Is serving your use case, the narrower
the use case,
the more effective your analysis.
All right,
so you know,
for example, building a face recognition,
uh, service that's not
a use case
that doesn't necessarily help you
tune how well that system is
gonna work
building a system or or specifying
a use case where you're recognizing the
face of a missing child or
you're trying to look up, uh, say
an actor in a library
of video, um,
those are more specific use. Cases you
can tune precision recall, you
can adapt your data sets, etc.
right so you want to go narrow and then you
want to assess the benefits and risks
of
of that particular use case
with as little dependency on the specific
AI solution as possible,
OK, and then you want to translate
the benefits and the potential risks
into release criteria
which are typically statistical
measures of a property.
Right? And so you have to worry about
confidence levels, confidence intervals,
thresholds, things like that, and
these, these properties will be intention,
right? But if you have that set of
release criteria, then you can think
about what data sets do I need to
support assessing those criteria, what
data sets do I need to build the system, and
you can think about the architecture of the system
more effectively, and then you proceed to
evaluation and, and, and through it.
Um,
so, benefit and risk analysis.
All right, I'll try and cover this quickly so
we can handle more questions.
Um, so an example of a
best practice in the framework, right, is
it's asking the.
Asking the builders to identify
potential harmful events that might
impact privacy,
OK, and you know if
we skip down to the agentic
AI
situation, right, you might wanna wonder,
well. OK,
let's suppose that I have
an exchange that Alice has an exchange
of information with Bob,
right, and appropriately shares
some information with Bob. It's a credit card
number, and then Alice has an, uh,
has an exchange of information with
Chris, another agent.
And appropriately shares
information related to that transaction,
maybe I don't know, Social Security number,
you know, but then it turns out that Bob
and Chris,
you know,
somehow later shared the same
memory store owned by the same
person and the information got aggregated.
OK,
like what is the risk of that happening,
right? Could that happen?
How would you drive that risk to zero, right?
These are, these are the kinds of questions you want
to ask early on.
Um, in this case,
you know, when you're thinking about an agent
and hopefully this is, this is pretty
obvious, right, you're gonna wanna invest
more time as a builder thinking
about issues
of adversaries and
resource constraints like what happens if I do
run out of money while running my agent,
uh, how do I recover from that,
um, and shared components.
All right, let's pick another
uh focus area, the release criteria,
um. You know, this is,
this is one of the really.
challenging.
Um, exercises in
building an agent
and
because of what it's asking you to do is
think about all the possible properties,
all right, and come up with
metrics for those properties
that you are most concerned about,
all right, and there is
like the science literature in many for
many pro for many properties is just
chock full of options.
you have, it's the inverse problem from
the one that Michael was talking about where a
lot of these, these deeper issues don't have
much research. Some of this has too much, and
what do you do as a builder, right?
Um, but you have to do the work.
You have to sort of go through and think about,
OK, if my agent is going to be
narrowly focused, how effective
are my safeguards at actually rejecting
requests that ask, you know, for example,
uh, an IT,
uh, based agent to go, you
know, answer something about a legal
issue, you know, you just don't want that happening, so
you wanna measure that particular
safeguard,
right? So you need metrics for it.
And you basically wanna map every
expected benefit and potential risk
to one or more release criteria,
all right, so that's very challenging, but if you
do that work,
everything goes way more smoothly.
All right.
Another area just to cherry pick a little bit,
data set planning
here with agents.
Because again,
the idea we're thinking about
the future where the agents are interacting,
you know, with different
information sources, other agents, what have you,
you need a simulation system.
You've got to simulate the environment,
all right, with, with Gen AI, with,
uh,
with traditional AI you
can have a more static approach
to your data sets,
but here.
Here you can't,
um,
or at least in many cases you cannot
and so there, there are simulation
environments that are beginning to pop up. The
UK Safety Institute has, has
one, Meta has recently
written by one,
but I would expect to see a lot more
of these kinds of sort of evaluation
frameworks begin to crop up.
Um, and then on the system planning
one, I mean, there's,
you know, I, I, I think sort of
the major message here
is that you want to talk, think
through the flow of every single
type of data through your system.
Like the flow through interactions
with different
um with different agents, different
humans,
um,
the flow through components and
the flow through logs and this is this is
something that is sort of part of best
engineering practices in many
situations so it shouldn't be,
you know, that much of a surprise
or a challenge
but it is very important in this case
where privacy is, is such a central
issue. Anyway, I'm gonna pause
right here and if we have questions, let's
take them. Michael, do you wanna come up?